all right so if i think about what's
happening today in the
kind of professional world especially
people who are thinking globally new
ways of doing business
in a lot of ways it just boils down to
what are you going to manage and how are
you going to prioritize and i think the
two things that are driving a lot of
people's decisions and actually
challenging
them today are how do you manage your
information
and there's a lot of information
overload and how do you manage your time
when there are too many demands on your
time and you've got to start making
choices
and i think what's interesting when you
come at it from a perspective of the
professional user
people that you're trying to help when
you're providing services online
using the behaviors and activities of an
individual to try to help them
make those prioritization decisions is
going to be incredibly powerful
so either how do i surface the most
relevant information to you when you're
trying to get business insight make
business decisions
um and act on information or secondarily
how do i make choices about the time and
how i allocate it in a day
those are some of the most fixed
resources you have and at the end of the
day
time is one of the most critical ones
that you can't you can't get more
right and so when it comes down to
making a lot of decisions how you spend
the time i think people who help manage
that with an informed insight about the
user's behavior
will have an incredible value
proposition
huge cool tremendous what else do you
want
well i mean i think at the end of the
day what we're talking about there's you
said earlier is optimization
right that's what we're looking for take
as much data in processes
and come back to you with this is the
best way to manage your time yeah
i don't know if you want to sure
particularly you know it's funny if you
got to go
big picture and look back and go add 20
you know go back 20 years and
you look at it and say what was the real
limiting factor for people who are
pushing their professional envelope it
was what technology could you could you
put in their hands
how do you actually make them more
effective by giving them technology
now the floodgates have opened and i've
got the blackberry i've got the
iphone i've got the ipad i've got the
laptop i've got the desktop and then
the list goes on and so how do i go
about figuring out how to
not constrain what comes through those
systems and so
everything becomes an optimization i
think technology is an incredible
enabler
and once the enabler's in place now i
think the
the bar that people are setting for
themselves for how do we deliver value
to professionals
is to start tuning what comes through
that enabling system sure and so that's
an active optimization probably at its
purest form
right filter it and contextualize it and
make it work for me and you know if i
look at ways that happens there's really
only three ways
you know i think a lot more about
information overload but i think it
would apply to time as well
you know one is as more and more is
coming at you just hunker down and
spend more time like you know do your
email at home at night and then do it in
the wee hours in the morning and you
just try to keep up with this
overload the second is some form of
artificial intelligence
right i can go and i can say some
algorithm will just tell me what to do
i don't think that's coming anytime soon
it may happen in a very
narrow scope where there's a defined set
of acts and i can tell you which one of
three
but i'm not going to walk in the office
on monday and have some system tell me
what i should do monday through friday
on all accounts or the third is taking
some
social graph and some intelligence from
the collective activity around
people that you work with that you know
and having that
provide me an ability to start saying
which one should be prioritized right
again an optimization act but i think
that's really where values will be
derived